# Videos for Free on iTunes!
(And Changes at Patreon)
Hello Internet,
Starting today I'm making my videos available
on iTunes for free.
If you click this link you can get them automatically
downloaded to your phone or tablet or computer.
-- and yes, before a thousand people in the
comments ask, there is an RSS feed for nerds
that you can plug into anything.
I'd love for you to click on the screen and
to give this a try because it's something
I've always wanted to make available.
Partly because it's convenient for you and
also because having YouTube as the only place
the videos live is a little scary.
Particularly lately.
So this is a safe place for the videos where
I pay to host the files so YouTube doesn't
have any control over them..
That's a big deal.
Now I'm able to make this for free for you
partly because some of the videos are going
to have a sponsor at the end.
I'm telling you this *before* the next video
because the other big reason I'm able to try
this out is your direct support on Patreon.
It's these two things that allow the videos
to exist independently from YouTube for the
first time without, from a professional creator
perspective, shooting
myself in the foot.
But I'm also concerned that some of you, my
dear crowd-funders, might not want to support
videos that are also sponsored.
If that's you, no worries.
We're cool -- that's precisely the reason
I made what you're watching right now: to
let you know in advance.
And of course, whenever I mention the crowd-funding,
I always want to make it super clear there
are lots of people who *shouldn't* -- I'm
looking at you in students in particular,
and etc.
For everyone else the crowd-funding should
feel a lot like sending Internet coffee because
you like the things I make.
And I like coffee.
It's not an obligation.
The crowd-funding does, however, allow me
to make video decisions based on interestingness
and now convenience and not just popularity.
And it also allows me to turn off kinds of
ads that I think are too intrusive like the
pop-up ads which I hate and I know you do
too.
OK, if you are still on-board, there are some
new perks over at Patreon -- I've expanded
the Wallpaper pack to include new VOTE ANIMAL
and other wallpapers, there's a wall-of-thanks
on my website, and a special perk for spoiler-loving
grammar Nazis.
You know who you are.
So that's the bottom line today: Crowdfunding
+ Sponsors = CGP Grey videos on iTunes and
RSS.
Click here to try it out and let me know what
you think.
I'm really curious to hear how this works
for you
### Post credits.
Obviously don't tell me what you think in
the YouTube comments, which are useless, Tell
me on Reddit -- where I can actually, you
know, *follow the conversation*.